este jueves las baterías tanto del
celular como del cuerpo tendrán que
estar al 100% en Ciudad Juárez a la
frontera con Estados Unidos El
venezolano Jeremy quiere estar preparado
para los cambios migratorios anunciados
por el gobierno de Joe entre ellos la
ampliación de 100 a 1000 citas
disponibles cada día vía la aplicación
cvp One para solicitar asilo tener
internet algo un poco que no vacía Los
bolsillos más que la comida porque son
casi 100 pesos cada tres días Este
viernes También dejará de aplicarse la
medida sanitaria título 42 que permitía
a las autoridades de Estados Unidos
expulsar de forma expedita a los
extranjeros que llegaban a sus fronteras
lo reemplazará el título 8 que dificulta
aún más el ingreso a los que no cuentan
previamente con una visa y el título 8
es deportación pura de 5 años hacia su
país y bueno ya es decisión de cada
quien si quiere hacer las cosas por lo
más legal posible o
hacer un ilegal y afrontar una
deportación a su país
todos esos Estados Unidos
El Paso Texas en Ciudad Juárez donde ya
se estima que 35,000 migrantes están
varados los albergues tratan de ampliar
su capacidad de acogida ahora que
estamos esperando esta oleada de
migrantes donde los albergues se van a
ver desbordados
y vamos a tratar de nosotros aportar con
lo que tengamos o sea vamos a apoyar
hasta donde nos alcanzan nuestras
fuerzas y nuestros recursos tenemos esos
esas colchonetas para atenderlos en el
piso una emergencia las autoridades
hablan de una congestión en la frontera
Esta media noche pero muchos migrantes
afirman que prefieren seguir esperando
su cita para garantizar una entrada
segura a Estados Unidos